foreign
lies a single solitary Peak
the dwarves are determined to reclaim
their Homeland
I like visitors as much as the next
Hobbit
I do like to know them before they come
visit it Mr Baggins at your service
and surrounded by
this is The Hobbit you asked me to find
the 14th member of this company and I
have chosen Mr Packers me no no no no
Hobbits can pass unseen by most if they
choose which gives us a distinct
Advantage we will cease this chance to
take back
where are you off to I'm going on an
adventure
ridiculous
foreign
buttons users who eats at home
fair enough
I will take each and every one of these
dwarves over the mightiest Army
loyalty
honor a willing heart I can ask no more
than that
home is now behind you
the world is ahead
thank you
well that could have been worse